because you you do stream to an english
speaking audience right like
how did you come to learn all of like
the english like internet terminal right
because it's kind of completely
different to the japanese one right yeah
sometimes i ask my chat
like you know oh what does everybody say
that's a dangerous game it's very good
chat is very educational and they're
very nice you have a very
rare twitch audience my chat just wants
to see me fail
always i remember asking them i was
playing a game they're like oh yeah i
was i wanted to know the ping of the
games like what's the ping and were like
oh it's all f4
and i just thought oh okay i closed the
game in a ranked match
i'm such an idiot sorry go ahead yeah
it's okay
because because like english isn't my
first language because sometimes like
people try to correct me
even though it's just obviously a typo
yeah yeah on twitter especially like you
cannot edit
sweet so yeah even though it's just
it's just obviously typo it's just not i
saw i saw people were correcting your
english
i mean that was like laughter sorry i'm
like yeah i was in a cosplay of laughter
character from you know iron broader
dolphins
and no i was obviously in a cosplay
because i could
i always like to make pants
or whenever i pause cosplay photos i
like to stay something that belongs to
the capture yeah yeah
yeah yeah so because like we are having
kobe 19
uh why don't i just use the term
laughter is a good medicine
okay but you know i put the laughter as
nafta you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah and some people just
correct me
that's a long sparring [ __ ]
but like on twitter there's always that
one [ __ ] because we make typos all
the time
and even if you delete your tweets like
immediately
they screenshot it they [ __ ] send it
to you like excuse me
i have this typo by giggup i know you're
trying to hide
like that is my absolute biggest pet
peeve when
it goes it's like two in the morning
it's like two in the morning and i'm
like
i'm just going to tweet something funny
and then i tweet it like 10 seconds
later i realized there's a typo
yeah okay no one probably saw that
deleter right and then maybe a couple
minutes later i do it again but the
correct spelling
the first 10 comments is always ha i saw
that
i saw that joey exposed for making a
typo joey doesn't know how to spell
and i'm just like [ __ ] it like happens
to everybody
yeah who are these people this is a call
now by the way
who are you what what do you what do you
get enjoyed what did you get out of this
it's like why are you so
it's like will you like just waiting for
me to tweet to like catch
up it's like chris hansen's like i got
him
did you think you were the only person
who got called out for typos english
okay it's not my first language
that's more of an argument of why we
should get it right yeah
so we don't have an excuse yeah at least
you have the excuse that it's not your
first language yeah yeah so maybe i
should have quoted like laughter
but i didn't want to make it obvious
like i just yeah i don't want to make
you like
a joke yeah it's really it's really it's
it's that ironic situation where like
the person correcting you thinks that
you're more intelligent about it when
you made a very intelligent joke that
they just don't understand right
but if you're smart enough that you can
just guess like i'm obviously wearing
golden hair
you know green eyes which aren't
obviously mine
you could guess maybe it has something
to do with cosplay because i
know the spelling i know that my english
isn't impeccable but at least i know the
term impeccable
something about myself that's that's
more than most english people honestly
please people but i do like sometimes
make mistakes like some
words like sounds similar like obviously
obviously
testicles tentacles like i sometimes
think but they're both belong to hentai
every everyday words yeah i make a good
laugh so yeah